les clubs de rugby vinoy sont passés par
toutes les émotions cette saison le sky
rugby fêter sa remontée en honneur après
trois ans d'absence
pour leur retour les saint-quentinois
ont lutté jusqu'à la fin du championnat
pour s'assurer le maintien il termine
finalement la sixième place du
classement
il faut pas en rajouter une seule chose
il faut toujours tout est plein de
petites choses pour que ça se passe bien
lafare être meilleur a physiquement
meilleur quelques joueurs qui viennent
un peu plus un peu plus chanceux sur sur
une blessure parce qu'on a bien chargé
cette année en blessure donc donc ça
arrive mais elle rejoindra peut-être
moins deux mois de malchance là dessus
et après c'est toujours progresser quoi
c'est à dire que là au match aller on a
fait on a fait trois victoires et au
maïs coton a fait 3 victoires + 1 nul
donc c'est mieux dans le championnat de
promotion honneur le promu montigny le
bretonneux a également flirté avec la
zone de relégation pendant la première
partie de la saison mais ils montrent un
réussi à se remobiliser à partir de
janvier pour terminer avec un bilan de
huit victoires pour 10 défaites et une
sixième place au classement
du côté de la fédérale 2 plaisir promu
cette saison restera dans cette division
la saison prochaine les plaisirs ont
officiellement validé leur maintien sur
le terrain de domont début avril
la victoire est sans appel 54 à 7
ce jour là les hommes de sébastien
roncalli compte 15 points d'avancé sur
le premier relégable
arras sportivement et de par le travail
effectué par les joueurs et tout le
staff et les dirigeants voilà je pense
que c'est tout à fait mérité
c'était vraiment très important
prépare vraiment des choses on s'est
projeté sur plusieurs années donc ouais
c'était vraiment important de se
maintenir cette saison
versailles a sans doute été l'équipe qui
a procuré le plus de sensations à ses
supporters après avoir terminé 3e de
division honneur derrière sarcelles et
bagneux et jour de la cité royale ont
réussi à se hisser en quarts de finale
du championnat de france en venant à
bout de l'entente maisons laffitte saint
jean les poissy sur le score de 13 à 3
un parcours historique qui s'est
finalement stoppé en quart de finale du
championnat de france verset s'incline
11 à 0 contre l'un des favoris chalon
sur saône pas de monter pour le club
ce qu'on retiendra de toute façon c'est
que c'est fait c'est une défaite à un
niveau historique pour le club
c'était la première fois qu'une équipe
senior du rcv atteignait les quarts de
finale en honneur donc vous avez oric le
voile à cesser les joueurs ont marqué
les cas l'équipe de l'histoire du club
avec leur staff
le championnat terminé les équipes
chinoises ont maintenant plus qu'un
objectif en tête sont renforcés pour
espérer passer un nouveau palier la
saison prochaine